hey cinephiles welcome back to another
edition of the monday morning review
with a side of spoilers i'm jay s and
I'm Alex and this morning we're talking
about Noah Noah uh this is not your
dad's Noah let's just say there's a lot
of artistic liberties taken oh yes a lot
I would argue this is a very thumb
attica rich movie I think there's lots
going on there's stuff taken from other
Bible stories that's just thrown in
there even though they didn't have like
a clear reference to Noah in the text
yeah I felt like I completely worked
here though it's an insane movie at some
point yes it is um let's just get right
into a first and foremost I think the
Watchers yeah um can you tell us a
little bit about these creatures the
Watchers essentially are these rock like
creatures and and what they explained it
as is fallen angels who take pity upon
the human race and they try to help the
human race out of there basically the
situation after after sin comes in after
the Garden of Eden yeah and they are a
very concrete and lots of you honey but
a very concrete form of the world
building going on yep where there is a
very absent creator or a god finger in
this film like it he only speaks to know
it through like these dreams and visions
study which is interesting because in
like in the biblical text it's like he
straight up told he's like yeah build an
ark and it gives him actual like
dimension instructions and what the
makeup and you know what to make it out
of and stuff like that and and initially
Noah has no idea what he needs to do um
well and and one of my favorite early
sequences in this movie he comes out of
his tent and he's just like or I think
he wit he wakes up from a dream and it's
a dream within a dream and he's
completely underwater and mankind
is just drowning it's an iterator for
heavy metal music and I'm just like this
is the Noah movie I honestly on it like
from aronofsky's they did a really good
he did a really good job in showing the
terrifying world mmm but like basically
why the flood showed up when i first
heard that aronofsky was going to adapt
his favorite bible story Noah I was so
excited because this is like a true
American out or I could look at his
roots like pie at requiem for a dream
like these are crazy movies was just
very creative filmmaking hit like front
center um and then after Black Swan
which is the only reason he could have
tackled a project this big because it
was a 13 million dollar budget made over
300 million worldwide you know after
that he was basically given free rein to
make whatever he wanted and so at that
point I thought okay he's gonna make a
really interesting version no just based
on his existing filmography this might
sound like a lame analogy but like the
Watchers themselves how there are these
big rock creatures with white bursting
through I almost feel like that's what
this movie is like and those lights
coming through our air nike supervision
um there's a moment when he's telling
his whole family the story in Genesis 1
best scene in the movie yeah it's an
amazing sequence and that straight up
perranoski you know if that's something
he it's probably wouldn't but like good
portion of this movie takes place on the
ark and after yeah and I wasn't
necessarily expecting that no and any
note that's actually where I had the
biggest qualm is one ok once of the
flood showed up you know which was
amazing and there on the ark I just I
guess to me it's like the the conflicts
that actually happened on the ark I
thought looked like tubal-cain for
instance giving getting on the ark and
Ray Ray Winstone I I thought he was
great just a job you read this role
pletely yeah and sometimes literally
other animals um like I thought his role
was really good I just didn't really
like that like dramatically his purpose
on being on New York my mom was kind of
like I was like ok he's there he's there
for like an obligatory fight scene but
it didn't really feel like he was
advancing anything we're like I thought
it would have been more interesting had
like the family had to deal with like
what if the animals woke up yeah if they
start eating each other like I feel like
those logistics are like almost
completely forgotten so that we can have
a lot more of these thematic arose like
this is just the struggle of good versus
evil know and I mean this this cane I've
character he's there to exist primarily
to Tim Tam I don't know what made
aronofsky decide what he decided but
like technically all his son's head
lives right writing into the arm yeah so
like I felt like okay fine they're gonna
try a different route you know whatever
but I felt like they kind of ran
themselves into a corner at the end with
like not having wives and and then
there's like this weird moment of like
this is typically kind of weird intense
relates assess us which is funny because
like that wasn't actually part of the
story yeah like it was like it's one of
those few instances in the Old Testament
were like that it wasn't him like a
potential issue yeah yeah and the story
there were just enough people but in in
this version of not quite you know it's
gonna be very interesting and the whole
like there's a story basically marrying
the binding of isaac what Abraham had to
do with his son yeah which I thought was
really harrowing stuff you know I had no
idea that this was gonna happen yeah I
was really shocked by where it went so
lots of surprises on Noah for sure um
would you recommend it to other people I
would recommend it but I would also
recommend to read the actual story later
because I see a good comparison so yeah
I'd recommend both yeah same here i
think it's completely bonkers but it's
it's beautiful
yeah it works as a blockbuster and it's
very thematically rich so big
recommendation from both of us in the
field so for movie clips I'm jeaious and
I'm Alex thanks for watching